this talk is a little bit different to
what you've seen thus far within within
this conference will imply data in fact
as a whole you have two people from the
information security industry that's
myself and Adam and information
assurance domains and you have one yours
truly data scientists who is presented
by data before and what we're here to do
is tell you how we can gather
information about you using public
sources that actually results in knowing
stuff which is quite private so we're
just going to take you through a little
bit of theory to start with and then
focus on the machine learning bit and
the analysis that's undertaken and we're
defining a new concept as well which is
that of degrees of separation of the
data that we use so a little bit of
background adam has extensive knowledge
in academia e works in in the financial
sector here in the City of London as a
risk manager Neri think the highlight of
academia was your master's degree in
machine learning and you're now
consulting here in in in the UK in the
same field and myself well a little bit
like Adam but with some more years of
experience okay what are we trying to do
so this is the tricky bit we're trying
to get non public data about you but
without hacking without actively
attacking it and we want to use what's
already out there on each of us how do
we do this well we'll collect data at
mass so think of you know the government
privacy versus security debacle that has
just come up again we focus on
individuals subjects which we're likely
to find more information on so think
about how you feel about reading
someone's descriptor on Twitter
right and we might then combine those
data sets to basically get new data
sources that we go in mind and in fair
whether or not we've got information on
our subjects okay but before we do or
any of that let's just look at a little
bit what we get taught in the space of
information assurance and information
security so if let's say that you
decided to shift your career now from
what you do into the world of
professional professional penetration
testing security testing vulnerability
management risk management risk
assurance risk control you'd probably
have to sit an examination after all the
vetted checks and everything added up
that you're not a criminal and you would
have to know something like this this is
a security model it's the Bella Padula
security model and basically it says
that you've got different
classifications of data and a subject
I'm a subject subjects basically cannot
read data up and can also not write data
down to different levels so let's make
this a little bit specific to
individuals and not governments or
organizations so if someone comes at me
point-blank and says outside of the
Adrian what's your date of birth I will
not give them that information so I'm
not allowing them to read up on a
specific data set on me and at the same
time very often information that you've
trusted on public locations online has
been gone and published that information
so your date of birth is probably
something that we can easily harvest by
just looking at your academic profiles
as one example and we'll go through that
in more detail so a little bit of theory
there's this thing called data
classification security models that lab
module is one of them and there's very
set rules as to how these behave the
reason why we're all here
is because there is a tendency in
today's social media and online presence
websites to constantly be writing down
information so we give something that we
trust people with and then they take
that bit of information and basically
make it available under certain
conditions okay so well let's look at
that a little bit from just a if you
like data gathering perspective so
there's a lot of public data out there
we all know the term of googling each
other right to find out who we are and
so on and that's represented by the big
sphere that you see here so over time of
course that lens changes so if we look
at the public data that was available
twenty years ago it wasn't that much we
went through a phase in the 90s and
early notice where we would register
openly with most online platforms next
to that public data we have what we
consider confidential or more if you
like personal information things that we
don't share but it's quite closely
affiliated with our public personas out
there all the different dots that you
see here represent different sources so
basically within the public data domain
we can within the public data domain we
can go and look at specific focus areas
and neri and adam are going to take you
through a very extensive analysis
example of that then there's things that
really secret so you don't want people
to find out things that your other half
knows things that your mother knows
about and that's you know that that's up
here and then there I say we're all
human so there are things that we've all
done that we're not particularly proud
about and probably will know
want to repeat again and some of us
don't have any such things but there are
things that basically you don't want to
come out now just don't focus on the
individual to think of organizations
think of governments think of
fraternities think of different groups
of people behaving in this man different
organizations have different
classification models so instead of
having four categories if you're in the
government sector you have something
like seven if you're in the US
government I think it'd be even more
layers there that the NSA provide and
there's also further classification
models in the UK we have I think the
upper echelons of top secret the code
word which is specific projects which
form a further bubble if you like so
there's ways that we classify data and
there's also different lenses that we
look at that data based on the sources
available okay so what are we here to
define them based on on all this
information so I'm not going to read out
all this slide but basically what we've
stumbled across is that if you take the
information that you find on a
particular subject which is probably
public and then you combine that with
another source that's also public very
often you get something about that
particular subject which is not so
public so let's think of an example of
this so if you take the fact that I've
shared with Google+ that my birthday is
in April and also you combine that with
some of the feedback on my Twitter feeds
around the time of April immediately you
can infer with a certain probability of
course what my year of birth was and
well similarly the day so we call that
just adding a degree of separation to
that data set
so a degree of separation on a
particular data is our ability to
basically combine that data with another
set of data sources of the same
classification in order to find out
something that we didn't know before
okay enough theory let's go through how
we do this so this is now the segue into
machine learning which is we've got all
these classifications and really what
we've done is we went and extracted
features and we give you some examples
of features and we stay away from
features on the top secret side here so
for example based on the public
information we can go and look at the
full date of birth the relationships and
basic date just quantify with a certain
probability as to whether or not we've
been successful and identifying
something that is not public about each
of us so without any further ado I'll
just pass over to nari for the analysis
how do we do this in practice yes so for
the analysis we decided to look at a
sample set of people and we thought what
better than to go for data scientists
since this is a PI data talk and maybe
people in this room or at this
conference will actually be in our data
set so we started off let's let's have a
look at data scientists what up does a
better place to buy in the collection of
data scientists than Twitter so we start
off with Twitter let's do some data
collection on Twitter well data
collection on twitter is quite quite
simple you've got an API to Twitter you
make an API OTP I'm not sure what
they've used tweet pea but it's amazing
tall to just connect to Twitter with so
you connect to the API you get some API
keys that that's quite straightforward
and all you have to do is really just
search for data scientists it's it's
that simple so the tie with any kind of
community all you have to do is just
start off and search twitter for people
in that category and you get loads of
data scientists or just two places by
any other kind of
look that you won't be targeting and
there you go so first of all we search
twitter for data scientists we get a
full collection of data scientist from
twitter we then do feature extraction
from that because twitter gives us back
the name a description that you give
when you actually join Twitter favor
counts whether your geo geo location is
enabled lots of people have a location
and language enabled so that kind of
tells you where you are and then from
that we actually do some machine
learning and we fit a k-means clustering
so we're trying to at that point kind of
sample down our data scientists and so I
get individuals so no longer are we
looking at a community we want to find
those figures in your community that are
lead figureheads so we want to go after
and look at who's important data science
and what have they be up to and what can
we find out about them so kind of like
know that down again we do k needs and
we turn cluster data scientists and then
find that important cluster that has
more connections and more people
following and just focus on that and
that's where our analysis begins yes so
let's make this a bit more interesting
right so I've got a data set of
seemingly very non intrusive information
that people were willing to provide on
the Twitter account some of them provide
more information some of them less
basically what I'm taking is I'm taking
this dump of Twitter data and let's look
at very simple data you have name first
name last name you have a user account
and let's just simply take that
information and I'll walk you through
the degrees of separations and what kind
of levels we can decrease we can
actually build on to so the first one as
I said public twitter people information
name location using it very easy the
next degree is um we're trying to do
kind of a personal individual matching
for that we can use different sources
there are people searching genes and
different api's for example people it
will provide you instantly with from the
information that we got from Twitter
which could be you know if you can have
a name that that could represent
different people because it's a popular
name you know the surname is not unique
with that you can actually drill down to
have a full name additional user names
or accounts and other aliases and
virtual presence that's the first degree
let's go further second degree we can do
from an individual matching going
further to kind of an account matching
and social matching and looking at all
different kinds of accounts that you
registered for so obvious one social
network present Google+ LinkedIn
Facebook photo sites flickr pinterest
and also you can have searches on
government sites lend registrations you
can look for car licenses voter's list
publications if you work in book attend
conferences you can look forward to your
locations Google Latitude auto mobile
data and those kind of accounts that
you've created we can match with the
personal matching the next degree would
be based on the information that we're
now building up is profile building so
based on for example google+ or linkedin
we can infer that you work somewhere or
you affiliated with a company and we can
look up your where you work where the
offices which city which building we can
look up your work email address we can
look for personal data right so we can
search for you when was your birthday as
the annus mentions you know some
information might be already available
and google+ the the month the date you
can look for tweets you happy birthday
to 30 you know 30th or 40th unit around
birthday you can look for personal and
email addresses you can look for and you
have a car you have a house did you buy
a flat and
all kinds of very interesting
information mobile obviously we're going
into the Internet of Things mobile
presents multiple devices and very
interesting space in terms of mobile
presence of a person and then you can
also have maybe some of you have a
private website personal website we can
look up registration data and where's
the person registered and where is he
living what's his telephone number
what's his email address that he's
registered for and then look up okay so
what's the email provider were you know
where he used that email address in
which profiles you can also do very
interesting search on images right so
you have an image uploaded on your
avatar in Google+ or Facebook you can do
image searches you can image matching
and so we built kind of a profile of the
individual and then we can go up another
degree we call that real time location
pattern building so for example you take
a picture to conference or at home you
upload that to flickr google+ but guess
what it has EXIF information it might
have geolocation and it might have what
phone you use them and you know what
plays at what time and what you know it
might even include comments of you've
ended with Photoshop on your macbook pro
right it has loads of information and
those are kind of example steps of
degrees of separation which can be
obviously build up shirt as well so just
as an example with a diesel know that
you can see that how this actually work
so how do you can get and data for
specific people we've picked narrow just
for an example so the starting point was
the Twitter account which is you know
seemingly very non intrusive data we
have a name and we have an account
username nothing more no date of birth
know you know nothing from that we
vanished linked it to her google+
account which instance we gave us
location data where she lives you can
have also behavior patterns where she
goes to the gym or if she runs things
like that on google+
you also find that she has a berth in
the twenty first of April but we don't
have a year so it's just you know one
additional information that we can build
up before on but guess what we can do
further searches and it turns out she
was born on the twenty first of April in
nineteen which is it 88 87 local ladies
we can we can see where she is working
where she at her education we can see
what kind of phone she is using from an
excess data and we can also see pictures
on what home from her wedding so you can
see this kind of build up can go quite
far right deep and you know you can
build up extensive information that you
can combine in link so what do we do
with this information this is kind of a
workflow starting from a data collection
of a simple twitter feed and put
information that we were gathering
through a pattern crept script and what
we're doing is we enhance that with all
these information that I walk through
the degrees of separation and then feed
that back into it and I hand over to
nari to show you how we do that but
first of all I think I must thank you
for not sharing any of my actual secrets
which I know you have found and said the
oil as well but obviously we want to go
back to the data science of it now we
now know what Adam knows and how we
should be doing this and how all these
data sources work together and actually
he's given me the sources of all of this
data so all we actually have to do is
combine it at mass so we have to build a
bigger picture of just not a few people
like we've been doing like it's been
building on me and a few other data
scientists but what we need to be doing
is building profiles and descriptions
for everybody in that particular
community and then we can use more
interesting machine learning things and
find those data points which are
actually quite interesting and which
actually secrets about people that we
can actually find
and which is out that and it's kind of
really scary that we can do this but
this combining is different degrees and
there's so many degrees you can only
find out things about individuals or
things about computer sees as a whole
how do we behave where we where we go
what do we do how to use as most more
effectively how do you get to this
community how do you infiltrate that
community so it shouldn't just stop at
analyzing and profiling individuals but
we should do that scale and use data
science and the skills that we have to
to combine our skill sets and do good
instead of evil obviously yes so collect
more data along everything again and and
all's well in the world pretty close
data sources basically so what happens
when we combine forces is I think
basically we were able to extract more
information that would otherwise be very
difficult to harvest if you didn't have
that zoom in perspective that Adam is
provided with the sources having that
then being fed back as knowledge to the
models that mary has put together meant
that straight away we were able to
basically gather more information
without having to worry about whether or
not that information is basically not
induced or inferred from public data no
active attacks would take took place
within the gathering of this information
so we didn't send anyone an email to
click on a link or actively pursue or
target individuals it was more about the
automation side of things on the second
bullets there are a number of data
sources in the public domain but by
themselves as singular entity entities
do not give you a lot
in terms of harvesting and sampling
their data but when you take those data
sources that we provided to nary you
have an extra edge in your analysis of
the data so the analysis aspect we've
called basically degrees of separation
in the context of us not getting
anything that is private about you but
adding another angle as to how we look
at the data that already exists and is
publicly available so in conclusion
you've learned a new concept out of
degrees of separation and hopefully
we've given you some food for thought
with regards to how you can combine
sources in order to infer information
which otherwise we consider private
let's look at if there are any questions
silence I can def again so as it as an
interviewer what do you do if you want
to do your public things but then at the
same time
people combined
maybe there's nothing much one of those
philosophical questions that what do you
make public
keeps on price but so very good question
there's a quote that says if you want
total security go to prison you will be
clothed fed the only thing lacking is
freedom along those lines be extra
careful about what you share and with
room that very often without having been
targeted people will share information
that really should not be out there and
especially if you're in the public
domain there is a process whereby we
take through people about what it is
that you should be basically putting out
there and what it is that you shouldn't
so an example would be don't use a
wireless hotspot that asks for your date
of birth I just don't use it that that
piece of information is more valuable to
someone taking a mortgage in your name
then that wireless connection will ever
be in your life so it's about just
balancing that trade-off how do you
learn about those
well you speak to a profession know that
there are no so there's a there's a
number of online resources on this
there's the safe and secure online that
there's a number of we we do training
within our community information
security and insurance community for
children in terms of making sure that
what they share online in their chance
is information that you know can be
shared so there are a number of
available resources online on this
what's care is that we haven't trained
the adults who are part of if you like
the first generation the second
generation is being equipped with
knowing how to handle this but the first
generation is not really the way it's
just add to that there's also kind of a
tendency that if you want to achieve
something we'll get something or buy
something that you're willing to give
more just in order to get that but you
should always think about in terms of
when you want to get that what
information do they actually need right
if I'll get them more which I probably
need to give them my bank details and
date of birth but if I I don't know you
know buy a book they should know what my
date of birth it doesn't matter right as
long as I pay so you need to kind of
think of what kind of information you
actually have to give to the person to
achieve what you want to but usually
that as any said with the younger
generation they're a bit more reluctant
to do that and also you can see that on
social presence but usually if i want to
buy the iphone out sign up for
everything right here i'll just click
yes yes yes and you know they want my
date of birth they want my email address
whatever i'll just give it right because
i wanted but you always have to think
about do they actually really need that
or do they require information because
once you hand it over it's gone it's not
in your you basically gave over the
classification
someone else or might be hacked and it's
out there and it's public there was
another question or is it I mean the
situation actually is actually I find it
even worse among the younger generation
because a lot of times there or if they
are already in the social network and
they sign up for certain childhoods or
ever and they're not understanding what
it means they will put on their real
birthdays right and all of that and
these are the question it's like for
example you want to up for bank accounts
is what you use right you wanted
punishment and Lane and all of this our
information that people can actually go
get them so it's actually i think the
cut is out of the bag i think that what
is more important is training the
organizations like linkedin and
Microsoft and Google never to ask those
questions because they are no culprits
they are the ones that created the
problem so what you are doing is giving
information licked a google plus they
are the ones that just a fluid and
people like yourself information
security should tell them this the
senior meat slicer eyes yes so I think I
think the question of the gentle in the
front row was one of well it was no
question it was a statement on should we
not be asking more of the big
corporations in basically being
responsible for our data being Microsoft
Google etc fair summary yeah I think I
think the only comment I would say to
that is there is a reason why all those
services are free so I have accepted the
risk that Google is mining me as an
entity on the basis of having a gmail
account with them having said that could
they make it more clear yes it's no
doubt Oh James
so I think one of the common criticisms
of supervised learning is its ability to
run circles around not a scientist by
inferring things that the data scientist
didn't quite expect the timesheet so one
of the characteristic examples of this
is the popular story about the super
expensive military project where they're
trying to discover camouflage tanks and
it turns out all the pictures of the
camouflage tanks were taking on a clear
day all the pictures of the non
camouflage tanks were taken on a cloudy
day and the trade algorithm can only
actually determine whether there was a
cloudy day or a clear day and didn't
work at all but it occurs to me that
this kind of deep mystical inference is
essentially potentially a mechanism for
side-channel attacks and I'm curious
whether the information security
community tries to do side-channel
attacks research via machine work for
the day whether they throw an enormous
amount of sensor data at something and
then try to see what can be inferred
from that and develop non targeted
attacks there you want to comment on
them well I think what I've learned from
working with these two can you repeat
yes if you could summarize James ok so
can does does the security industry mine
a lot of data to kind of find attacks
exact a facsimile of your question and
specifically our site Renault si si shat
on tap where you are trying to for
example your time and for somebody's
passport listening to that strokes the
keystrokes event a right
the sound patent was induction of some
circuit inside the computer result on
some anti yes so I found that a lot of
security people are really aware of the
data science skills at all technologies
even available so they do a lot of stuff
boot for us so they have their ways of
getting that side channel attack anyway
because of the way they do things that
plant bugs they'll hack into your
computer and get a keylogger but they're
not only using that massive amount of
data to kind of do that yet so I think
we have large opportunities to combine
our fields which isn't which were not
only there yet as employee being done as
of yet because the skill sets just
haven't been combined as much as they
can be so I think that we should be
working together more in the security
industry to kind of prevent these
attacks as well because obviously this
this might just be happening right now
just not aware of it so for work both
for protection and I'm only for
protection we don't want to attack
anybody so just just to add to that so
James if if we were part of a criminal
organization and wanted your date of
birth we would get it and on the
attacking technique you always use the
attack that requires the least amount of
energy so standard principle it dates
back to ancient times so we would not
use passive techniques like this because
basically that would be an objective now
where you're not talking to criminals
but professionals vetted professionals
that would not be an option plus it
wouldn't be morally correct to do that
without your consent so where we now see
a spike of such activity is with
governments mining data up to the limit
of what they can harvest without being
in breach of current privacy regulations
and there's a big debate on security
versus primers I think we're going to
see a lot more of that
because more and more people don't want
to break the lower power yes let me ask
follow but bottom line he has approached
is this dragnet approach I think
side-channel attacks are typically
attacks where you have a specific target
so for example if you wanted to guess my
password the typical approach would be
try all the common passwords or thought
of mind some information about me try to
name it my dog the name of my first high
school rebel but you can think a very
common thing of machinery would be sit
me in front of a camera and have any
type of my password 100 times and then
notice every time I type the W character
I blink a little bit deeper and then
infer from that my passion right and
these very weird inferences kept
collected over large large numbers of
done and you could think that if you
could use that to a for a sizable tackle
for example there must be some
physiological response from something
types of cancer or type certainties
there's certainly an auditory response
related to the travel of the tweeting
different keys we might be able to
discover side-channel tags to target
specific individuals guess their
passwords or it seems like that that
might be completely indefensible because
how do you change your breathing to make
sure you're not you know revealing
information through that side oh yes and
ultimately you know the human is the
weakest link there I mean there's no
there's no other down to grant it I I
don't think we've got time for another
question so I'd like to thank everyone
for attending and hopefully you blood
something